on savait bien qu'au fond les arguments
utilisés par là comme ailleurs par les
partisans du livre étaient des arguments
entendus terme grossier à la serpe
parfois même carrément mensonger parfois
même des mensonges qui ont été reconnues
aujourd'hui par les partisans du livre
donc on savait bien que le débat au fond
avait quitté le domaine du rationnel
est ce que c'est bon pour l'économie
britannique ou pas quelles sont les
conséquences quelles places pour la
grande bretagne dans le monde ont des
arguments rationnels est parfaitement
légitime pour ne venir que sur le
terrain de l'irrationnel et quand on est
arrivés sur le terrain de l'irrationnel
on n'est jamais sûr de ce qui peut se
passer mais quand on entend par exemple
l'ancien maire de londres assuré
aujourd'hui que la coopération entre
l'europe et la grande bretagne va se
renforcer
comment est-ce que vous réchauffer s'est
vidé là aussi qui était une illusion
pour ne pas dire un mensonge qui a été
longtemps porté par les partisans de la
sortie de la grande-bretagne de l'union
européenne c'est que ça ne changerait
rien qu'au fond ils perdraient les
inconvénients et gadret tous les
avantages qu'ils réclament aujourd'hui
n'avons pas cessé de le redire pendant
tout le débat que par définition leur
décision aurait des conséquences et des
conséquences sur la grande bretagne et
dire pour la grande bretagne ou au
détriment de la grande bretagne mais
nous ne la croyons nous ont barré
nous n'allons pas de nous changer de
langage oui alors la position de la
france elle était affirmé très tôt
d'ailleurs par françois hollande y
compris face à laquelle d'ailleurs la
position aujourd'hui de l'ensemble des
partenaires européens oui notamment des
pays fondateurs mais pas de démolition
c'est la position de tous ceux qui
aujourd'hui font les décisions en europe
elle se des résines très simplement on
ne peut pas traîner traîner ses de
l'incertitude de la certitude sont des
inconvénients qui peuvent être graves
grave d'abord pour la grande bretagne
oui grave pour nous aussi donc on ne
traîne pas et si c'est là dessus que se
fait le raisonnement des responsables
européens
si les britanniques pensent pouvoir
commencer les négociations sur qu'est-ce
qui se passe
et sans avoir enclenché la procédure
dite de divorce mais non la clarté c'est
vous avez décidez vous enclenchez non
puisque vous avez enclenché on discute
la grande bretagne va pas rester un pays
sans aucune attache avec le rsa n'ont
plus de nom mais il va pas nous forcer
non plus ah oui voilà donc on est dans
une situation où aujourd'hui il n'y aura
aucune négociation sur la suite tant que
la grande bretagne n'aura pas déclencher
va que tôt possible au divorce et je
vous assure
voyez que c'est ce qui va créer le plus
de problèmes la grande bretagne parce
que ça crée une incertitude monstrueuse
pour l'ensemble des acteurs économiques
en grande bretagne c'est l'intérêt
profond de la grande bretagne que de
commencer le plus tôt possible
la négociation est donc d'enclencher le
plus tôt possible
le projet précédent on leur dit vous
allez ajouter de l'intéressé dès données
déjà vous qu'elle est regardée
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui même regarder un
peu ce qui s'est passé sur les marchés
les marchés à bout java 305 jour à
l'autre donc il faut regarder ça dans le
moyen long terme
enfin on voit qu'aujourd'hui la
certitude lc pèse sur le dos des anglais
des britanniques on a entendu le premier
ministre dénonce et les thèses
ultralibérales et l'austérité budgétaire
fait que vous mettez en oeuvre vous même
alors vois plus mon pas donc il n'y a
pas d'austérité en france
si vous voulez que vous explique ce que
c'est d'austérité on va aller en grèce
on va aller au portugal on va aller en
espagne mais je n'accepte absolument pas
la critique david de l'austérité en
france on est une famille quéveau
sérieux doerig tête mais rigueur une
politique sérieuse qui consiste à faire
en sorte que nos déficits n'explose pas
de les diminuer pour maîtriser notre
dette vous allez c'est un langage que je
tiendra indépendamment alors entendre
dès qu'on est sous le joug de bruges
donc je vous réponds que je ferais la
même politique indépendamment de
l'europe parce qu'elle est bonne pour la
france donc nous faisons en france ce
qui est bon pour la france
et ceci est cohérent avec les politiques
qui sont par ailleurs menées
vous souhaitez en europe mais je le fais
parce que c'est bon pour la france
vous n'imaginez pas les français ne
veulent pas aujourd'hui que la dette
qu'ils reportent qu'on reporte sur leurs
enfants continuent à augmenter
donc il faut évidemment maîtriser donc
on a une politique mais j'étais sérieux
cette politique est nécessaire dans tous
les pays qui par ailleurs
morand d'équipage la même je ne rend
aucun compte à bruxelles c'est pas comme
ça que ça se passe
heureusement donc s'est taillé un
dialogue avec bruxelles qui est chargée
de vérifier que tous les pays ont des
politiques cohérentes vous pouvez pas
avoir la même monnaie l'euro est par
ailleurs avoir des politiques
budgétaires complètement différente donc
c'est normal
dix d entre nous pour rendre les choses
le plus coriace d'ailleurs on aurait
besoin qu'il y ait de la cohérence aussi
dans d'autres domaines qu'il y ait la
cohérence dans le domaine fiscal
une harmonisation fiscale qui est la
cohérence dans le domaine social une
harmonisation sociale ou 10 s est battu
par exemple dans un autre ministère
contre les travailleurs détachés les
facilités offertes et on sait que ces
directives sont dévastateurs nombreux
mais pour le bâtiment en français
également même l'industrie est
aujourd'hui attaquée alors jusque là on
a péché par naïveté je sais pas si c'est
par naïveté en tous les cas à d'autres
moments dans les années 90 ont été
adopté des directives dont on voit
aujourd'hui qu'elle provoque des dégâts
considérables
il ya bien des corrections de tir qui
est ce un dock et des corrections de tir
qui s'imposent pouvoir il est
parfaitement légitime sa carrière c'est
ce que 2 propose le premier ministre l'a
juste titre et quand il dit la relation
au peuple il a parfaitement raison
regardez qu'est ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui vous avez une europe qui est
depuis 2007 2008 est encore dans la
crise grosso modo qui n'a pas retrouvé
le niveau de richesse individuelle
d'avant la crise on rend des comptes la
longueur presque dix ans jamais l'europe
n'avait connu ça depuis 1945
on comprend qu aujourd'hui il ya des
interrogations on comprend qu'ils aient
un salon deux peuples qui se disent mais
peut-être que c'est à cause de l'europe
même si en l'occurrence c'est il faut
pas faire reporter par l'europe toutes
les responsabilités nous avons aussi
chacun d'entre nous nos propres
responsabilités
chaque gouvernement dans chacun des pays
et le tout depuis dix ans donc il doit
subir et vous prenez vos les regarde
alors prenez votre part alors j'imagine
pour le début du week-end chacun sa part
de respecter vite et je pense ne l'ont
fait ce qui était nécessaire mais parce
que on avait un dérapage monstrueux de
nos déficits parce qu'on nous a laissé
une france où je vous parle voilà quatre
caricatural véritablement dans un état
désastreux quand vous voulez de faire en
sorte qu'un état désastreux soit corrigé
ça peut faire mal pas alors après la
part d'auto critique qu'on a entendu
quand même
les communistes vous faire entendre les
critiques d'arnaud montebourg dans une
interview au monde ce soir lui il estime
que
qu'il faut dénoncer la politique
d'austérité extrémistes et autoritaire
dictée par une europe antidémocratique
il accuse françois hollande en fait
d'avoir appliqué la politique de la
droite allemande alors que lui
répondez-vous il répète les mêmes choses
depuis déjà quatre ans oui mais là il se
sent un peu porté par ce qui se passe se
comporter devant le peuple
il est un de plus parmi beaucoup
d'autres a jailli à dire des raids dans
le slogan il y en a assez des slogans il
y en a assez des slogans ces slogans la
n'apporte rien
c'est comme ceux celui qui dit il faut
absolument un nouveau traité sympathique
un nouveau traité mais ce qui
m'intéresse moi c'est qu'est ce qui a
donc nous retraités et la dot qui
visiteront un référendum mais un
référendum pour un référendum mais ce
qui compte c'est la question pourquoi je
vais mexique françois hollande a bien
orienté le rôle assez de passer des
slogans que ce soit des slogans critique
vis-à-vis de l'europe où que ce soit des
slogans qui on s'en serait l'europe
on peut pas simplement sauter comme
disait quelqu'un de son siège en disant
europe europe europe
ça n'apporte rien de concret aujourd'hui
au peuple justement c'est ça le divorce
des peuples avec ce qu'on appelle
l'europe
il leur veulent du concret il y en a
ras-le-bol des slogans anti ou des
slogans pro il faut être dans le concret
aujourd'hui il n'y aura pas de
conséquences dommageables pour la
croissance française
mais il faut faire très attention c'est
l'incertitude qui est la plus mauvaise
cette incertitude qui va peser
monstrueusement sur la grande bretagne
mais qui bien entendu pèse aussi sur le
reste nous alors c'est quoi le risque
alors concrètement la de 7,1 cm quand
nos mines ou quand vous avez une
incertitude avait des gens regardaient
prenons en prenant des gens qui
investissent en europe mais qui sont pas
en france ou en grande-bretagne mais qui
sont au japon ou en chine
quand il regarde ça de loin ils disent
pas la grande bretagne seulement ils
disent l'europe dans l'europe il se
passe des choses et des choses donc ils
se tiennent sur le bord ils vont pas
prendre la décision qu'ils avaient
souhaité prendre c'est cette incertitude
que nous voulons briser le plus
rapidement possible dans le secteur
bancaire plus spécifiquement que qu'est
ce que vous attendez comme conséquence
est ce que ça peut être positif comme le
pensent certains en ramenant une partie
de l'activité
à paris où est ce que au contraire y
avoir une forme de concurrence par
exemple réglementaire qui favoriserait
la place londonienne
alors qu'est ce qui fait la force de la
place londonienne parce que la place
londonienne c'est considérable dans le
pipe britannique qu'elle qui fait sa
force c'est que en étant à londres on
est en europe
on est dans le reste de l'europe il ya
par exemple des banques américaines
american américaines qui ont une filiale
à l'ombre ayant une filiale à londres
elles viennent faire concurrence à nos
banques européennes sur l'ensemble du
territoire de l'union européenne
c'était en une des raisons pour laquelle
cette place c'est beaucoup développés y
compris depuis l'entrée dans le camion
mais alors c'est bon que ça ne servira
plus à rien d'être à londres il faudra
avoir les pieds que dans l'union
européenne
douze apôtres amsterdam ça peut être
ferons quoi fêter que les banques
perdent leur passeport bancaire parce
que c'est une chouette c'est la
conséquence obligé est obligatoire et
c'est pas la peine d'avoir des illusions
sur ce point c'est la conséquence obligé
est obligatoire de la sortie de l'europe
c'est un pays comme on dit dans le
jargon un pays tiers avec lequel nous
avons avoir des négociations c'est
légitime mais prenez la suisse elle n'a
pas de passeport ou ces banques n'ont
pas de passeport pour venir autant dire
qu'il n'y a pas d'alternative et
aujourd'hui aux banques américaines
installées à part la city focale
viennent en france soit pas la seule
manière de faire pour ses bons si elles
veulent continuer à travailler cela noté
rythme et a contrario est ce que vous
risquez est ce que disait stéphane
effectivement que londres devienne un
paradis fiscal est là en gagne une
nouvelle concurrence féroce
il est placé européenne mais pourquoi
bon aujourd'hui nous leur notez donc
jeune andreu ne pas fusiller cessé de
résonner un peu bonne pourquoi
aujourd'hui londres
c'est la première place au monde qui
fait des transactions en euros quand
même étonnant puisque c'est justement
une place non pas dans l'euro c'est la
première place qu'il faut parce que ils
sont intelligents ils sont ingénieux il
ya des infrastructures il ya des sommes
importantes qui sont échangées c'est
l'intérêt pour beaucoup d'acteurs en
euros de venir faire leurs affaires à
londres ce sera fini demain il y aura
plus même ath type acquis rapide échange
d'euros à londres mais ça va continuer
considérablement diminué donc
ya un an je sais où ces transactions
vont elles se faire et transactions au
bon sens du terme je parle pas de tout
ce qui peut concerner la spéculation
mais où ces transactions ou une grande
entreprise qui a besoin d'emprunter en
euros va-t-elle aller emprunter au mieux
qu'elle le fasse à paris j'avais trouvé
très désagréable lorsque le premier
ministre avait dit mais je vous en prie
le tapis rouge est déroulé venez de la
france vers la grande bretagne
si vous avez peur d'être trop imposer
enfin mr je devais oui je suis plus fair
play que lui car je ne vais pas avoir le
même valeur au léger dit l'autre jour
que le tapis rouge rester en place et
qui pouvait fonctionner dans les deux
sens vous êtes d'accord quand même avec
valérie pécresse la présidente de la
région ile de france qui elle déroule
elle le dit le tapis bleu blanc rouge
elle a raison il faut que la place de
paris soyons disons les choses très
clairement la place de paris c'est
l'ensemble de ceux qui sont actifs dans
les domaines des maraîchers dans le
financement des entreprises de
financement des états il faut que cette
place de paris aujourd'hui se renforce
laquelle a les capacités
si des décisions sont librement prises
par d'autres
elle a les capacités de les accueillir
dans de bonnes conditions il n'y a
aucune raison de se priver de cela
si la vie de dire aujourd'hui que la
situation est difficile et en
particulier difficile pour le président
de la république la réponse est oui
les difficiles est ce que une situation
difficile est une situation qui rend
impossible toute évolution dans les mois
qui viennent la réponse est non c'est
d'ailleurs même le coeur de l'action
politique
l'action politique ce n'est pas de
constater qu'il se passe quelque chose
aujourd'hui et que forcément dans neuf
mois
ça sera la même situation l'action
politique c'est de faire bouger cette
occasion la faire évoluer et en
l'occurrence dans le sens que l'on
souhaite que moi je souhaite c'est à
dire une candidature du président a
répliqué dans des conditions qui lui
permet de faire valoir son travail de
faire valoir ses résultats de faire
valoir ses propositions qui se demande
qu'est ce qui pourrait empêcher
aujourd'hui une candidature de françois
hollande lui s'il décidé d'en faire
autrement
et dans ces cas là il se passe quoi mais
je ne raisonne pas comme ça donc je vais
vous poser la question qu'est ce qui
peut l'empêcher lui parce qu'il est
libre d'être candidat ou ne pas être
candidat je souhaite profondément qui le
sommet pour une raison simple qui est
très terre à terre peuvent en parler
c'est d'être un peu concret je ne vois
pas d'autre candidat à gauche qui
pourrait mieux certains diraient partant
de d'une situation difficile mais
pourrait mieux rassembler la gauche que
lui je ne vois pas d'ailleurs à chaque
fois qu'il en a un de plus qui arrivent
je n'ai pas le sentiment que ils soient
plus rassembleur que son voisin est près
à tout cas certainement pas plus
rassembleur que le président république
aujourd hui pourtant ça très mer on se
dit que ce n'est plus forcément le
candidat naturel
non je ne pense pas cela je je je répète
que un président de la république
sortant est assez naturellement
considéré comme le candidat comme
candidat à senna répond jérôme ans par
une primaire oui mais c'est une primaire
de même nature que celle que nous avions
auparavant ce une primaire pour
rassembler une primaire si si si il y à
une primaire si le président républicain
candidat est éteint mais c'est une
primaire pour rassembler et je pense que
c'est bien vu ce qu'on appelle la gauche
de gouvernement
c'est à dire celles qui aujourd'hui
participent à l'action je dis pas celle
qui contentent heureux
la gauche mais j'espère que la gauche
qui fait le gouvernement j'espère que
s'il y a des primaires des primaires
dans les conditions qui ont été
proposées par le parti socialiste me
paraissent solides il y aura des
candidats solides et vous savez ce que
ça veut dire ça veut dire que ceux qui
sont candidats
ils s'engagent à une chose est à une
seule c'est de soutenir celui qui
gagnera la prime est sacré vous savez ça
s'est passé le principe c'est celui que
nous avions la gauche ericsson qui
rentre dans cette primaire est
réconciliables par définition puisque
dans une primaire de la gauche de
gouvernement
ils s'engagent à soutenir celui qui aura
été décidé donc ici pour ça que c'est un
certain moment le premier moment de
rassemblement
perrino disait c'est très difficile pour
lui de rassembler est-ce pas simple mais
ça c'est une moment le jour venu qui
permettra je pense sera autre chance
c'est d'avoir un camp fracturé en face
de vos sais pas si c'est notre chance en
france l aréna léo c'est la réalité tous
les jours y en a une plus que le même
territoire avec les mêmes arguments
je suis pas sûr que ça apporte beaucoup
au débat politique globale enfin ça
montre la diversité notre de celle qu'on
appelle parfois l'autre gauche non pas
dans le lobe gauche de gouvernement j'en
vois pas d un nombre considérable il y
en aura suffisamment pour qu'il y ait un
vrai débat et qu' il ya un vrai choix
encore une question sur cette première
vous avez dit solidaire et arnaud
montebourg dans le journal le monde
aujourd'hui dans son unité a lieu dit il
fixe un peu ces conditions pour y
participer il veut dix mille bureaux de
vote le même système de parrainage qu'en
2011 des listes électorales de la
république donc nous sommes tous les
électeurs et en somme il dit que cette
primaire a n'est pas loyal mais je sais
pas comment il peut enfin on voit bien
que c'est une forme d'échappatoire que
de considérer à l'avant ce que quelque
chose n'est pas loyale ce qui est une
manière en quelque sorte dès maintenant
d'annoncer qu'on est capable d'être
candidat hors de la primaire mais s'il
veut être candidat hors de leurs
primaires il le sera avec 15 autres
ça vous inquiète 15 mais non ça mais ça
m'inquiéterait si j'étais parmi les 15
autres parmi quinze autres si par contre
il veut et on peut le souhaiter
construire un premier étape de
rassemblement avec ses différences et
s'inscrire dans la primaire qui sera
organisée par le parti socialiste dans
des conditions qui n'ont pas de réaction
pas fixé mais qui n'ont pas de raison
d'être fondamentalement différente des
précédentes
as
moment-là il commencera à participer au
rassemblement je préfère un montebourg
participant à sa manière au
rassemblement cas monde mais pour qu'ils
en rajoutent dans la division le 12
juillet emmanuel macron à tenir un
meeting à la mutualité et la même annulé
devrait même annulé un déplacement
diplomatique en sommes pour pouvoir
tenir ce meeting est ce normal
comme dirait quelqu'un c'est un homme
politique donc lille agir d'hommes
politiques des hommes politiques les
hommes politiques ils le font du
porte-à-porte les hommes politiques
il s'exprime sur des sujets même parfois
sur des sujets lorsqu ils sont ministres
qui dépassent leur leur territoire
propre et quand on est un homme
politique on peut tenir des meetings
donc il tient des meetings politiques et
d'autres il en fait trop ou quelque part
si on vous entend entre les lignes pour
un ministre il en fait beaucoup
ouais en dehors de ses activités à
verser vous le voyez quand même encore
oui bien sûr et j'ai très bonne relation
avec lui et je lui dis d'ailleurs les
choses de la même manière je pensais à
mon ministre c'est qu'elle vous a pas
alors blessé quelqu'un non seulement aux
quais du talent parce qu'on n'arrête pas
dire qu'il a du talent mais karen à
venir kaka est venue quelque chose que
vous évoquez quelque chose mais il faut
qu'il soit clair il est dans la gauche à
milan un gouvernement de gauche et donc
et à gauche donc pareil puisque dans un
gouvernement de gauche
il faut pas qu'ils hésitent à le dire
adacore à vous prouver qu'il devrait
peut-être te dire davantage
alors on se tenait dans la vie politique
d'aujourd'hui il faut pas être dans la
précision puisqu'il a raison de penser
qu'ils le 2017 c'est pour être son tour
déjà je suis aussi le banc et je l'avais
dit on va dire vous m'avez écouté par
ayew la tâche paraît oui par exemple
vous l'a pas dit